do you think one day ai may allow us to
do something like basically crack open
physics so do something like travel
faster than the speed of light my
ultimate aim has always been with ai is
um the reason i am personally working on
ai for my whole life is to build a tool
to help us understand stand the universe
so i wanted to and that means physics
really and the nature of reality so um
uh i don't think we have systems that
are capable of doing that yet but when
we get towards agi i think um that's one
of the first things i think we should
apply agi to
i would like to test the limits of
physics and our knowledge of physics
there's so many things we don't know i
this is one thing i find fascinating
about science and you know as a huge
proponent of the scientific method as
being one of the greatest ideas
humanity's ever had and allowed us to
progress with our knowledge but i think
as a true scientist i think what you
find is the more you find out
the more you realize we don't know and
and and i always think that it's
surprising that more people don't aren't
troubled you know every night i think
about all these things we interact with
all the time that we have no idea how
they work time
consciousness gravity
life we can't i mean these are all the
fundamental things of nature i think the
way we don't really know what they are
to live life we uh pin certain
assumptions on them and kind of treat
our assumptions as if they're fact yeah
that allows us to sort of box them off
somehow yeah box them off
but the reality is when you think of
time
you should remind yourself you should
put it off the sh take it off the shelf
and realize like no we have a bunch of
assumptions there's still a lot of
there's even now a lot of debate there's
a lot of uncertainty about exactly what
is time uh is there an error of time you
know there's there's a lot of
fundamental questions you can't just
make assumptions about and maybe
ai allows you to um
not put anything on the shelf
yeah not make any uh hard assumptions
and really open it up and see what
exactly i think we should be truly
open-minded about that and
exactly that not be dogmatic to a
particular theory
um it will also allow us to build better
tools experimental tools eventually
that can then test certain theories that
may not be testable today about as
things about like
what we spoke about at the beginning
about the computational nature of the
universe how one might if that was true
how one might go about testing that
right and and how much uh you know there
are people who've conjectured people
like uh scott aronson and others about
uh you know how much information can a
specific plank unit of space and time
contain right so one might be able to
think about testing those ideas if you
had um
ai helping you build some new exquisite
uh
experimental tools this is what i
imagine you know many decades from now
we'll be able to do
you